President Biden and Kamala Harris
ratcheting up the racial rhetoric at a
Juneteenth celebration at the White
House
the past few years remind us our
freedoms have been put at risk by racism
that's still too powerful for us to heal
the wounds of Divisions so racism no
longer tears us apart
we have to choose to be Believers in a
dream doers of the world let us look at
the sacred freedom to vote the freedom
that Generations fought bled and died to
secure
the freedom that is under assault in
States across our nation it seems like
Joe Biden isn't even trying anymore at
the whole Unity thing but his White
House thinks it's a priority
he's been very clear when he ran in 2020
was about bringing the nation together
right the soul of the country that's
something that's still a priority for
this president he's had multiple
multiples you know remarks on that
particular issue uh Greg happy June 10th
yeah why aren't we taking that off you
know oh I have it off it seems like as
Americans if we don't take this
seriously it's racist yeah so I'll be
taking that entire week off
um what a loser they are uh that a party
is a bunch of losers because they've
been at this for 50 years and they're
just saying it's not working like the
more they work Against Racism oddly the
worse it gets it's funny that the
rhetoric used by democrats becomes more
intense more extreme the better race
relations are and that's because there's
a fear that removing the division will
do two things one you'll have no need
for a consultant so an activists and
race Hustlers and racialist authors you
know you need a war no one's going to
buy your bullets uh and if we stop
fighting amongst ourselves then we kind
of figure out wow this really isn't
about race it's more about as you say
the uh the subway versus The Uber class
and you focus on the elites who are
trying to keep us apart the Damned need
to keep these divisions fresh or else
they lose their power and that's what
this is about it would be great to unite
about and agree on the continued success
of the Melting Pot but they are saying
nothing is melting and you have to sit
you have to stress the separation so
that's why you're seeing more
segregation at colleges because of this
tortured mentality do you think the race
card is working for Joe Biden and Kamala
Harris well it didn't work in Georgia if
you look at Governor Kemp's reelection
right remember that was where they the
Democrats including Stacey Abrams and
Biden himself chased the Major League
Baseball game out of the uh out of the
state that infuriated a lot of people
there and there was all these lies about
Jim Crow 2.0 remember that then you
actually fact checking like actually
that's not what that says DeSantis won
re-election by what 61 of the vote and
his increased with African-Americans and
Hispanics quite a bit so no I don't
think it's working at least in the
states where they want to be competitive
and I think that if you look at most
recent AP poll showed Biden approval
among black voters down to 58 percent
that was in May it was at 90 percent
earlier in the presidency wow so what
happened I would say inflation
crime
immigration and education especially on
school choice covid policies and just
feeling like kids are not being taken
but well that they say that the
government wants to basically take care
of your children whereas parents are
saying no we want to take care of our
kids and besides in a lot of the schools
in Black dominated districts the kids
can't read and they can't write so the
parents are rising up and want something
different you're the pollster at the
table
or at least you say you're the pollster
do you think independent white voters
when they hear the Democratic president
call them racists and call the country
racist do you think that turns them off
I don't think that that's what he's
doing I think that acknowledging that
there still exists systemic racism and
challenges for black and brown people in
this country doesn't make it that white
people are bad it's just we're a work in
progress and there's still more work to
be done and that's what they've been
trying to emphasize their agenda for
Black America has had a lot of wins we
have right now the lowest black
unemployment lower than the levels when
Trump was there I know that's what
you're about to come back with the
highest level of black entrepreneurship
it didn't even work you're still talking
somehow uh highest level of black
entrepreneurship in 26 years you have
the investments in hbcus 100 billion for
black small businesses why are their
numbers down then well the the approval
versus the intent to support is also
very different because
they're not being given another another
viable option and Donald Trump did
perform better with black voters than
any other Republican it looks like he's
on his way to be the nominee
um we'll see when his indictment trial
um comes in all of that but there's
something really crucial that
Republicans keep doing that is a major
turnoff to the black community and
that's insulting Kamala Harris so you
don't take someone who's so meaningful
to that community and say that she's a
diversity hire that if she hadn't
when I speak for the black Community
First you know you realize
he's one percent I am one one percent no
one's giving it to you we have Johnny go
out and speak to the black community two
times a week and they do not support
Kamala Harris no
okay speaking very broadly there if you
have one of the highest achieving black
women in the country who's now made it
to the vice presidency and Republicans
and people who talk about her on air say
she's a diversity hire she'll only get
where she was going because she slept
with Willie Brown that she's
embarrassing
she slept with Willie you just said that
is that not true
no of course not I love it when people
accuse us of spreading rumors by
actually citing rumors wait so does this
work with with the left too though like
did they get upset when you know Tim
Scott runs her president and the women
of the view attack him horribly or
Clarence Thomas is called an interesting
a traitor to his race because he happens
to be one of the most successful black
men in American history and yet he is
not a Democrat I mean I don't know if I
necessarily buy that argument that if
you don't like Kamala Harris who's been
widely criticized by black media by the
way like Charlemagne the God for example
podcaster not impressed with her record
on Criminal Justice Reform and joking
about smoking weed when she put lots of
black men in jail for the very same
thing I mean I think there's a lot of
issues within her record as the Attorney
General of California with that
community and what she's decided to do
now but it was rallied but I would say
you know in terms of the the strategy by
the Biden campaign and the vice
president to use Juneteenth as not a
moment where they can say wow we had
this amazing reconciliation in the
country we've moved forward together how
can we capitalize on all of the gains in
Congress exactly and and yet they use it
as a way to divide people to act like we
haven't gone forward in this country and
the final thing is that she keeps
talking about in Her speech that freedom
is under assault and that it's for
racial purposes in States across the
country she's talking about voter
Integrity laws and as you mentioned Dana
in Georgia they passed one and they
claimed that it would be a
disenfranchised black voters well black
turnout went out went through the roof
it didn't disenfranchise anybody and it
took away Stacy Abram's top campaign
talking point because it didn't turn out
the way that she claimed it did so they
could use it as a way to move the ball
forward for Unity but instead they have
to keep taking people back well I for
one I'm just still stunned about this
Willie Brown situation I'm going to have
to research this I might even have to do
it on seven o'clock
get Jessica on you know I'm busy this
evening
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else